okay
what up guys
all right as usual um because i always
have technical difficulties i'm gonna
make sure this is working because
sometimes it does
other days it doesn't let me know if you
guys like the sound
how
it's coming off uh let's see
um
okay i am in fact live cool cool cool
all right guys what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels went live with nicki minaj
what
what
two legends
met
two um before i start okay you already
know do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos y'all if you have
watched two or more of my videos or one
or more of my lives as a matter of fact
if this is your second live
subscribe to the channel
or we have beef
okay beef like respectfully beef okay
um i have my starbucks today
i know i said i was gonna be sober i'm
not
mama i'm so sorry i'm not sober anymore
okay guys
let me know in the chat i'm gonna
readjust it so it like looks better do
you like me small or do you like me big
and i can go here
first person to let me know in the chat
gets to decide
first person in the chat to let me just
put in the chat
which way you like me big or small
because i could i could go either way
also also another thing while i'm
waiting for someone tino give me their
input
um
the next thing so right now i
i'm so grateful for all the donations
we're gonna have um the live show
most of my equipment's getting delivered
today i get the sound board
i ordered two mics
so i'm gonna have four mics total okay
my goal is i want to bring in like six
to eight people in here i think that
would be a good number okay you like me
big this small
is that what you're saying stun dog then
the power of this video is in your hands
okay
i think six to eight is a good number
i'm at four so any donations that you
guys donate during this stream
um
they they will be going directly towards
the equipment
um i i want to get the show up and
running by the 20th that's my goal
so
um yeah um these the mic that i'm using
now are about like 130 pounds like 200
bucks each so my goal is to buy like two
more of them so it's like 400 ish
bucks
yeah so any donations also if you want
to donate like directly to me
the email
is for paypal it's hannah h-a-n-n-a-h
perl p-e-a-r-l davis d-a-v-i-s gmail.com
cash app is the same as my username so
it's just pearly things
okay um i'm hoping this is what you
meant
i'm just gonna assume it is
you like me big okay
let me make sure i'm on the screen okay
guys
kevin samuels and nicki minaj
i am excited for this
you see
i heard was blood clots and [ __ ] i'm i'm
old
everybody
i love the universe and i am a firm
believer of the universe okay listen i
wanted to get one and talk to you for a
very long time is that right
that's very right what we got
so i wanna know
what you gotta you know let's let's have
this real talk let's have this real talk
um because i know a lot of times when
people will speak to you
they
it's like they trying to be funny
and and i feel and i feel like if if if
you call somebody
trying to be funny yes
i think i feel if you try if you call
somebody trying to be funny then
don't be mad at what you get if it
wasn't like if you called somebody i
love nikki okay nicki minaj she's a
little crazy but i in my opinion
everyone that works in entertainment is
a little bit crazy
like you have to be crazy to want to do
this
i'm a little bit crazy
they're a little bit crazy like everyone
is a little nuts on the internet like i
genuinely believe that um
but what i like about nicki minaj is she
actually like
she i don't know she makes sense
sometimes like she's talking about like
the vaccine and stuff i thought she made
sex really trying to you know sincerely
ask questions or get information or chat
then that's different
so
i want to talk to you okay
what are we talking about
well
what what do you rate me
is that what we're starting off with
yeah
do you think the women do you think that
men rape women
no i thought cause that isn't that what
you okay
pause what he says do we do i think that
men rate women
every time
i've talked to men about like what they
would rate a girl one to ten they have
been way more generous than i would be
like even talking about like girls like
not me
have nothing to do with me right
and i'm like oh i'd give her like oh
maybe a five guys will always rate the
girl higher than i would have thought
oddly enough but not kevin not him
and i don't think it's like
that um
the guys are just like trying to be nice
or like the gynocentric social order to
me it's like men are attracted to like
most women to be honest and i didn't
realize that until like six months ago
you do
that's
what have you seen in my content have
you seen have you just seen like the
clips
yeah i well i think i always see people
calling you and they and then you and
you tell them you ain't no such and such
you lying to yourself you ain't just
what i typically don't do is i don't
typically rank people i ask them they
rate themselves i usually ask these
questions so let's start it that way
yeah how tall are you
i'm 5'3
my dress size
benzodiazepine um my dress size
that's a good question
um
i i guess fly
all right
and on a scale from
well nicki minaj she is very skinny but
she has like a huge but
like ginormous i'm like what the
anyways one to ten you can't use seven
what would you rank yourself
fresh race out of the shower just you
yeah
as i always ask the question
okay i would give nicki minaj
it's hard because i don't know what she
looks like without makeup and all the
surgeries i'm sure she has
has had but i would maybe give her
like an eight
i think if you profit i know like the
manosphere would probably disagree with
me
but i'm a little bit more realistic
because in the real world okay the
average woman is 150 pounds
if nicki minaj walks into a room i
guarantee she's gonna be like the top 20
of people in attractiveness i guarantee
seven
can't use seven
that's why seven is the most common
answer
really
it's the default answer for most people
because they don't want to go too high
they don't want to go too low
um well no um it ain't a default answer
for me
i'm surprised i when i saw this i
totally thought she was going to say
like i'm a 10 i'm a 10 i'm a 10.
because in her her music is so
i don't want to say empowering but it's
very much like i'm i'm a boss i'm the
[ __ ]
like it's very much like
holding up women so to speak so i was
not expecting her to say seven
i would let's see
i'll give you a nine
i will give you nine because
yeah that's the highest rating i've ever
seen kevin samuels give someone ever
i've never seen him give anyone an eye
the facial symmetry
and you get additional points for eyes
oh full lips
see it's not
i'm an actual image consultant
you have a symmetrical face
and so it's much more based upon facial
symmetry it's not based on european
beauty standards oh my god guys did you
know that you can change your facial
symmetry by how you breathe anyway
that's this is a different broadcast for
a different live
but
google james nester that's all i have to
say
it's much more based upon
what babies animals human beings have
evolved to find attractive
wow you get and you get additional
points because
we've evolved to find yeah someone in
the comments said she's a 10 just eyes
and lips alone i'm like
guys
i think okay there is a celebrity scale
and there's a real world scale okay
when i look at hollywood
it's a bubble everyone in hollywood is
eight to tens pretty much
the occasional
sixth
girl that's like an adjustable six with
a great figure
but most of those people are profiting
off of their looks most of them are
eight to tens
but you put them all in one room the
eight to tens don't look like eight to
tens anymore because they're in a room
with everyone that's eight to tens
like so in hollywood i don't think
nikki's like crazy hot because
she's in a room with ever like the most
attractive people on the planet
but it's kind of like what's her face
like kristen bell
in any room eight to ten
any any normal room but in hollywood
yeah she's like six
more
sir
you're gonna get blocked you know who
you are in the chat
one more comment you're gonna get
blocked guys someone attractive
especially when they're not on aging
wow
wow
that's not what gets that's not what
gets translated most of time people take
my clips
and cut it down to something that's
gonna make a viral moment it's gonna
start a conversation
take the good with your bad
have you seen anything else that i did
i saw one time when you checked this
lady
for i think i guess it was a white lady
or a hispanic lady and you was like oh
you're not gonna come on this show and
talk down on black women that's what the
[ __ ] you're not gonna do
and so again that was a clip i didn't i
didn't see the con text
really but
well
i get a i get a rap of hating black
women uh and it's far from that i mean
there are over 50 black women report
that they've gotten married as a result
of watching my content really it's on my
this on my instagram i actually had a
young sister uh this post up saying hey
as we said to you i smashed the ring i
just actually posted a brother who was
about to move to the dominican republic
and he found his
wife in my facebook group
like 12 couples have gotten married in
there but that stuff doesn't get
publicized
but when i'm talking about relationships
i'm talking about
men and women but because i'm black i'm
talking about
us
and time to time i would bring stuff in
and then a lot of times sisters will say
men when they get to a certain level
they only want
white women it is that
um so i i let women from other races
come in like okay well
can you learn anything from what would
you it's interesting because as a white
girl um
who i've had like black i've had a black
boyfriend in the past i've had like more
than one
and um
but i don't discriminate like it doesn't
matter like that stuff just doesn't
matter to me i feel like black guys
it'll be like one of two things like
either
i don't date black girls or like
like white women or trash like give me
like black girls only
like that's that's what i've noticed
there's like
two types
but
i feel like
i don't even know like latina girls is
like the most sought after i don't know
if that's just in my head but i feel
like guys in general latina is like the
most sought after
and
the one woman came in and she thought
she was going to
do what i did to black women
oh wait wait
now i we can talk this way those white
women in hollywood are not really eights
or nines they're really fives and sixes
margot robbie get out of here you're
telling me margot robbie is a five or
six
please please get out
karen you sit your ass down over there
cuz i don't play that
i'm i wouldn't let you know
despite popular opinion i love my mother
i love my dollar but we do have to have
a
family conversation and it's
what's starting to happen more is
actually we're starting to have more
conversations about this it ain't
comfortable
but uh we're starting to see progress
well let me ask you this just outright
then why why do successful black men
date outside of their race
um
well i would say this when i look at men
i look at it i split them up guys i
consider being industry
music entertainment athletics any guys
on the business side
business side because i come from that
side but uh
more often than not black men want to be
with black women
85 percent of black men are married to
black women oh that's what
that's what's interesting is there's
always this narrative that
like black men always stay down and
always marry out but it's just not true
and thank you so much for the five
dollar super chat i really appreciate it
just so you guys know all donations go
towards um the mic that i'm saving for
so right now
i have
four maybe five if i can get the fifth
one to work mics for the podcast that
i'm setting up it's going to be called
the pre-game
and it's going to be like basically in
college all the girls from my school
like my athlete friends are going to
come over and we're going to have
discussions about like different red
pill topics
um so all money is being donated that's
being donated is going towards the
equipment does that make sense okay
oh
when i
when i had my guys come to me even after
they got themselves together
like dennis furling the guy who just
moved he found this black wife in my
group
black men wanted we want to be with them
the problem is
let's be honest
in my lifetime we weren't really raised
to learn how to get along with one
another we can kick it
we can hook up
and we can we
work together long term
and uh
i mean you're married now right
okay marriage is a relationship it's a
skill set
it's different than dating in short term
we really want to talk that kind of
stuff and
what's successful oh my gosh
you learn so much in every single
relationship to be honest like
they always say like beauty is wasted on
youth and that's how i feel about
being like young and naive because
every single relationship it's like
you can either come out one of two ways
you can come out damaged or you can come
out wiser
and it's like it's up to you what you do
with it
who are doing good in their professional
life
want to fail in their personal life
and in the black community in particular
when we fail in our personal lives
we pay a huge penalty because so few of
us get married
it's almost like we like to see people's
marriages fall but we need more of those
things in order to build
that's the thing people
single people
single women keep women single that
that's so true like
even me i just
got out of a relationship and like
the the reaction is always yay like you
can go out with us again you can do this
with us again
and
it's never like
oh go back to him you might have made a
mistake like i've never seen someone
dump their boyfriend and the girls say
oh
you might have made a mistake
maybe go back to him
i don't know
but it's hard because when you're single
you want to hang out with your single
girlfriends when they have a boyfriend
it's like
they can't come
whatever we're going to be because
um that people
may not like my method but
i want to see more black men who want
black wives get with black women
and that's the outcome of giving it
ain't pretty though
sometimes they ain't pretty
can i say something can i say something
real quick
black women can y'all can y'all can we
can we start stop talking about
if these [ __ ] want us or not
excuse me kevin this is not
i'm talking to black women real quick
can we stop talking can we stop
posting all day on to because i i re i
knew we went to tik tok and i and i just
kept seeing this black women can we stop
talking about if black men if these
successful black men want us or not like
can we just focus on us and we be
successful and then we go out there and
we decide who the [ __ ] we want
because okay there's one thing i think
she's insinuating which is false
if you want success with men focus on
your body
like improving how you look don't don't
focus on your
career
sadly it's i mean
i don't want to say it's sad because
it's almost easier to focus on your body
rather than your career
but when you are driven i think there's
like
a lot of us want
to be
men to be attracted to that but they're
just not they're not built like built
like us that's what we're attracted to
second thing
i say this all the time i just don't
care who doesn't want to date me
and we'll have these like big
discussions on youtube talking about
like
those men don't like these women or
these women don't like these men like
do you know how how much of a
like guys
would look if they if they started
protesting because women don't like
short guys
i'm sorry i openly discriminate against
short men i'm not going to date you
and if you guys want to come on here and
say well you're only competing for this
small percentage look it
i'll compete
and i'll get that small percentage
because i i'm six foot guys
i discriminate like but i just
i'm i'm a six foot ginger that's not
like you know the quote unquote beauty
standard
but i don't care who doesn't want to
date me
it just does not matter
what i've been seeing is i feel like
i've been seeing men
using that as an opportunity because
they they've been hurt and and somebody
doesn't put them together and they've
been using it as a as a way to come out
and lash out and poke fun at black women
and use it as a way to feel like they
somebody or they something or so so for
all you [ __ ] that's doing that i want
to talk whatever the [ __ ] y'all at eat a
dick go away nobody gives a [ __ ] about
you and i want black women to stop
[ __ ] posting about whether or not
y'all y'all y'all want black women or
not okay what i want black women just to
focus on themselves be successful and
then you go out there and you decide the
trajectory of your life
okay
well here's here's the thing
nicki minaj's facial expressions kill me
there's a lot of hurt on both sides
and a lot of and especially in the black
community we don't really do a lot of
couch there is a lot of hurt oh my gosh
there's so much her in dating it's like
women we don't want to be used for our
body
okay so
like we
i mean that's like i think in the back
of a girl's head like our biggest fear
is one like catching something right
two
like sleeping with a guy and then him
never like talking to you again or like
even a guy that you you guys are like
intentionally dating like you don't know
if he's lying to you you don't know if
he's doing whatever right
a guy
it's the opposite he doesn't want to be
used for his wallet so he just want to
put all this time into a girl
and put all this money
all this time effort all this stuff into
her
just for her
to leave and go give it to give it to
another guy for free like that that
makes the guy feel sick the same way
being used for our body like makes us
feel sick
and
when you have both parties going into
this like out of fear
basically like
trying to both like
looking at the other trying to make sure
neither of them are like trying to pull
one on them
it's not that's not how you start like a
happy and healthy marriage
that's the that's the issue we're in
modern day dating especially with like
dating apps and stuff because you can
ghost someone so quick
like
so quick on both ends you don't have
mutual friends like
you can be in and out of their lives
like that
therapy
i recommend therapy often
because we got a lot of stuff
individually that we want to deal with
and marriage and relationships are not
for everybody and i'm just trying to
ultimately ask people
what do you want what do you want
and what are you prepared to do to get
what you want and are you willing to pay
that cost it's really the conversation
but it always gets kind of whittled down
but at the end of the day
what we are seeing is
you know especially if you're under 30.
it's it's harder for guys to date under
30 than it was from 50 years ago because
you can't take care of a family
on a high school or just coming out so
they have to mop so i think that that's
more of um
i don't i don't know this for sure but
what what it seems like kevin samuels is
talking about like
dating under 30 is harder for men but in
my experience like
most of my friends just date guys that
are around their age maybe a couple
years older like five or less
and
date them for like two to five years and
then get married like the age gap thing
i really only see
in like different cultures in different
communities i don't really see that
i
was dating a guy that was like 15 years
older than me
briefly
and i was telling my family about it and
like that i was like the talk of the fam
they're like he's so old
what are you doing
then this man
sprung kids on me that i did not know
exist yeah that's that's the story for a
different day different day
um
and i reckon i just had men's and i
recommend i told guys look why are you
under 30 work recognize work on getting
yourself together
because like it or not
you're really not in a position like
like you should be to be able to work
with lead do anything like that
um
and
you see the hate not the hate but the
hurt on both sides because
a lot of times people will use these
talking points to go at
and poke women over here but
that's not what's going on right now
this year we're past the sound we still
laugh we still we still do all that
stuff we're talking about self-awareness
um
and moving the needle i'm being late
tomorrow talking with uh
a famous sexologist a woman is feminist
to talk about things that i might not
that people on my side may not
understand to further open the
conversation up because that's what we
have to get to we gotta end up for
whoever want to be involved with whoever
we got a feminist hold on guys i'm
trying to
i'm i think i thought i thought i was
making this better but i think i was
making it worse okay
um that's so interesting he's gonna be
on with like a sexologist
and they're having a better conversation
because while we're separate fighting
everybody else just eats off of us
that's really what it looks like so
okay kevin
so since we had no we got we gotta we
gotta get down to been a chat
now do you think a man can can can
um have sex three times a night for his
for the rest of his life
what
three times a night oh my god
you guys are how much free time do you
have
you guys are wild they can't
not for the rest of his life huh
well how many times
they gonna be able to do it here's how
much he's working
listen hold on
how many times
should
a man
expect to have uh sex what is in your
opinion how many times should a woman
get how many times i don't know
oh gosh
should i call my mom a nap no no
i'm wild and no no no no no i can't call
my mom and ask man
sex
a week
a week
uh
i'm a fan of the as often as he wants
because here's the thing
here's the thing
you look at like i said i look at guys
most guys i'm talking to working
10 12 hour days
bernie mac said i'm gonna come home get
you 50 strokes you counting me for you
guys if you ain't got time most dudes
trying to walk around like they're porn
stars look here man
get good before play easter [ __ ] and
get on because oh my god this is one
thing that i learned
about men is like
men aren't gonna be like wilden if
they're just like content with what they
have like most of the time it's it's too
much work for them to go out and find a
new [ __ ] so if you just give it to them
as much as they want like it's just
easier
for the most part i mean
there's exceptions like celebrities and
yeah you know
we gonna have all that time we get old
our back hurt and hips out
oh no
when you get older you do it three times
a week and you're good that's it
okay i don't want to talk about this
it's too personal i mean i think
i think a happy sex life
two to three times a week is what most
people are doing because they got on
stuff
kids yeah no i i know when you're single
no i understand because yes things
change when you have to be looking at
your baby and you know a lot of you know
i get it i totally get it but um let me
ask you something
do men really want because i was having
this discussion
two days ago do men really want a woman
to be all up under them
uh like well like oh baby hi
or do they just say they want that and
when they want that and when they get it
they'd be like because i feel like me
being mean
is what
oh my god okay i don't understand this
either there is something about men
there's a certain type of guy that likes
a [ __ ]
okay there is i don't care what the man
of sphere says
i'm i'm very nice and i'm very much
like i do too much to be honest i'm like
i'm a pushover
and sometimes in dating
that has helped me
but other times you kind of get passed
over for the girl that the guy like
feels like they can't they have to like
earn almost
but what i've realized is like long term
that doesn't work because like i think
the older a guy gets he kind of gets
like tired of that [ __ ]
um
and i was having this discussion with
someone the other day
and i was telling her because she was
like
like pearl you have to play these games
with guys and i'm like look no
i am not afraid to tell a guy i like him
if i like him then i like him and i will
let him know and i don't understand like
why we have to play these
she's like oh play his games i'm like
why
for what and i'm like look at if you
want to like be in in control
the most powerful thing you can do is
make a man feel needed
like you need him
if you're playing like you know the
control power games i guarantee that
will get you further than being a [ __ ]
to him
guarantee it but you know
you let me know
patrice the late great patrice o'neill
said it the best
we want you around but not around he
made the comedy bit we said we want you
in the house kind of like around the
corner in the vent somewhere
we kind of want you to be like a cat you
calling cats man hey babe okay you there
cool we just want to know you in touch
this is my problem i don't shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't shut up so i'm like that cat
that's always there but doesn't stop me
yelling
meowing like 10 times a day
it's really always
i feel like i'm like a man i feel like
i'm
you know a lot of people throughout my
life would tell me
that i'm like a man because i remember
yeah she has masculine energy and
everyone acts like
like everyone has some level of
masculine and feminine energy everyone
does
and i i sort of relate to like girls
that are like hard workers because guys
i can work like 12 hour days i can i can
work
i'm a workhorse
and
and that's that's not feminine right
that's like that's more of masculine
energy right
but and but i kind of prefer i was
talking about this on
on my
last live i kind of prefer guys that are
a little bit feminine
i don't
call me crazy i don't know little beta i
just i like him like nice and like funny
sorry
call me call me a beta or call me a
call me an alpha him a beta whatever
but i'm not i'm not i don't know oh my
gosh
red pill guys think a lot like thank you
so much for the donation i appreciate it
so freaking much
that is 15 i'm buying two more mics for
the podcast i'm trying to get the
podcast out by the 20th
so on the 20th of the month i'm gonna do
a podcast with girls from college from
my college they're gonna be female
college athletes they're hot guys
and right now i have four mics and a
sound board my goal is to be able to buy
two sound boards and have eight mics
total so i can have eight people at the
apartment
but that's that's gonna be like
five six seven eight it's gonna be like
another thousand dollars but we raised a
thousand dollars in the first week you
guys were so helpful
and like for real i i could cry with how
how thankful i am for your donations
like i could not get this podcast
running without you guys
you just want a little beta look at guys
everyone has some alpha some beta like
girls are still attracted to this beta
qualities
like as as rolo tomasi says you look for
the perfect mix i don't know
call me call me crazy
i shouldn't want to i shouldn't expect
as a woman
to
have a climax every time i do it right
hilton and i said excuse me are you out
of your [ __ ] mind why wouldn't i want
to climax every time i have intercourse
just like you want to climax when you
have interquest and i was i was accused
of being like a man
not in my you know i'm this is years ago
and i knew that wasn't going to work
chad cause uh it's not only about you
i do not like those type of
conversations
oh i don't like those type of
conversations
i i feel like as a girl you should be
able to tell a guy like what you like
like it shouldn't
to me sex is like not the most important
thing at all like i
that comes like last on the things i
care about like to me like
a man's like work ethic values
all that stuff is like way above sex
um
like i just think as women
i wouldn't advise that someone puts that
much emphasis on it because if you do
that means you've kind of slept with a
lot of people
to like know
i don't know
who think about that oh my god thank you
so much for the 10 super chat you guys
are gonna make me cry on this live
thank you okay 25
of the new 900 goal
because the new goal is 900
for the next set of equipment you guys
helped me through the first round
you understand you guys know what i'm
saying okay well well so when i go to
l.a i'll be talking to sexologists
uh you know shambu dream shambody um
there's a lot that men don't understand
about sick oh sham i know her
oh she's great do i keep
sorry i keep like moving forward and
missing this up okay
most guys you asking what the karma
sutra is they don't know what it is
they don't know anything about tantric
sex they don't even know that you
couldn't even show them the anatomy of a
vagina they can understand parts
just weren't tall
so
and
you know
uh if you know what you're doing yeah
you suppose yes you should have as much
orgasm you should you multi-orgasmic you
can have more than we can that's right
so the point is
look at nikki
she's like come on
but i'm just saying like sex
that i don't think that should be that
high on your list as a woman like
sex is a skill it can be learned it can
be taught you know what can't be taught
values moral character ethic chemist
ethics chemistry that can't be taught
sex you can learn
like what
like we're not even supposed to be out
here wilden they used to get married at
like 18
17.
i think my grandma was married at 18 she
had like two kids
you think she was wondering like
the man i'm having kids with like is he
stroking me like
gross
i think when are you going to get cash
up i have cash up just pearly things
that's me on cash app
just pearly things one word
it's also hannah pearl davis i have two
i forgot i made two like a while ago on
accident but yeah i have two cash apps
that was part of the purpose of going
down there to have this conversation
because women's sexuality is so
misunderstood by men
so a lot of guys make comments about
women and not knowing and they make
decisions based on women and i say
ultimately this if you ain't getting
married what the [ __ ] you care about a
woman's body count and who's your
[ __ ] okay you ain't gonna take
ownership of it and if it's yours you
need to learn what to do
oh that's interesting if you're not
getting married then who cares
yeah
it's hard because i genuinely think that
we were not meant to have sex with as
many people as people are having sex
with today i don't i don't think this
shit's natural but i also don't think
there's any going back
like hearing stories from like
like my sister and like their friend
group and like all that stuff i'm like
y'all are
wilded
but i'm sure like my generation like the
generation 10 years above me is like oh
my god y'all were wild in like every
generation just seems to wild more than
the last generation
so now we're here there's no going back
like women women aren't how we used to
be especially in the west
so now it's like what do you do about it
is the real question
because uh yeah well if i was a man i
would still care about who a woman is
[ __ ] just it just safe safety as long
as it's clean
i'm talking about there are guys who
yeah and i i 100 like understand the
argument with like
like
wanting
how do i put it like
wanting a girl with a low body count i i
get that i understand i will never tell
a man not to like want that but the
question is
those girls are rare right
so that's so so the man of sphere says
right either they're rare or they're not
rare
and based upon what you guys say in
dating
i don't i don't mean women that are like
as wild as you guys say but
but
you say they're rare they're not common
those are your friends pearl okay okay
fine so so
so i'm right or so i'm wrong let's say
what do you do now
we have this whole dating pool of people
that have like just effed everybody like
i don't know it's not natural
worry about it
things here's the thing there's
ownership and then there's dating
a lot of we do a lot to disqualify one
another
um
and we got enough stuff already
disqualifying us oh right right to put
women down yeah
or to discount men too and i'm like well
in the context of a relationship
it's different than people who are out
here just hooking up
um
if you're gonna have you come just about
here hooking up you need to be
i i would assume you would want to have
a good sexual
reputation who want to be a dead lady or
a weak [ __ ]
that's not um that's not a good look
yeah
people like i'm so lost
no i'm not lost i'm talking about people
oh i want to put it one i want to put it
on a person i don't give a [ __ ]
well
uh yeah i've seen the videos all right
what the what was what were you talking
about the blood what is the blood what
is that blood clot
i know what is that no it's just it's
just a term that my family my jamaican
people who i love very much it's just a
curse word that they use like with a
bloody lady i did it with posts
you understand so that
i've never heard that a blood clot all
right i've heard that before i'm like i
know it was a cursor
all right cool
but good to be on here with you you got
any other questions because i gotta get
past
gotta finish talking to my people but i
want to tell you that i appreciate you
joining me tonight
um and and i don't wanna i don't wanna
and to everybody that's wanting me to um
to dis this gentleman or anything
i'm not going to do anything because i
don't have proper information and i
don't do [ __ ] to get attention or to get
clicks or i mean to do no clown [ __ ] if
when if i hear something and i
understand the context and kevin and i
want to talk then we'll talk but i'm not
just here to this nobody so
if i say you see you don't like feel
free to talk about it i will i will
we're gonna have to have you on queen
radio in a month or two okay let's do it
all right take care
oh my god i loved that collab that was
so fun that was oh gosh other one that
was literally so fun
what is my cash app it's just pearly
things or here let me look it up because
i have two on accident i didn't mean to
actually i'm just gonna put the one
that's up right now in the chat
it
is that is my cash up i put it in the
chat
um
okay so he was trying to leave before
she spoke there are men with low sex
drives who worry about a woman's body
count with high sex drives who are good
at sex with their present partner
oh gosh the body count question
is tough right i i would tell women to
like keep your body count as low as you
possibly can right
and
i would also tell men
to you know
get a girl with as little experience as
possible
but but here's the problem
we're in
a society you can't
hook up with guys right and we're
already in a society where girls are
hooking up with guys earlier and earlier
they're getting on birth control earlier
and earlier the body counts are going up
and up
this is where we're at guys so what now
because they can't
they can't undo it right
so it's kind of like
and same with the guys like most guys
are going to make the same amount of
money just just like i would tell a girl
you know
go for the best guy you can you can get
it doesn't have to be money alone but
like based on money values character all
that stuff but money is the only one we
can like tangibly measure right
but it's like what what can you get most
guys don't make crazy money
i don't know am i making sense sometimes
i say things and i'm like i don't even
know if i'm making sense right now
it's kind of like we're in the society
where we're at there's no going back so
now what do you do
because the average age to get married
is 27.
um
and like 30 for guys
i don't know i don't think this shit's
natural to be honest i think it's very
unnatural
i think
life will be better if people just dated
intentionally and got married
earlier what if girls lie about it yeah
and that's the other thing you're never
gonna actually know
like
there's this
you're never gonna actually know what a
girl's body count is ever so
so it's kind of like
like because i think the argument on the
other side is why stress about something
you're never gonna actually
know
just remember guys if all women stop
giving up their body that means you have
to
give up trying to convince women to give
up their body
that comment doesn't really make sense
uh the average woman lies about their
body count oh my gosh
other correct answer would be the woman
determine their body count oh for sure
for sure but i'm saying like the average
age to get married is 27. i think the
average age to lose your virginity is
like 16.
like i got lucky because i was like late
to the game to be honest but like
like i'm just saying that's like 11
years of hooking up with people
like
i don't i don't know what the average
number is
okay i don't i don't know
all i'm saying is like
it it's not what it used to be like we
we society has changed so what do you do
now that's the question um
you can know if she's a virgin though
yeah and but the question is can you get
a virgin
only you only you know the answer to
that
can you get one because most virgin
girls want a guy that's super involved
in the church i have a couple friends
that were virgins and waited until they
were married to have sex and do you know
who they married they married guys that
are very religious that was what was
important to them a relationship with
god
they both got married at like 21 22.
um
um
11 years later so for 11 years straight
there screwing not
oh my god i don't know what they were
doing in the 11 years
[Music]
i don't know
i didn't interview them i'm just saying
like if we run the numbers
16 27 in the u.s
and i'm pretty sure in the uk it's like
31.
so i don't
i don't know i don't know what they're
doing
um
hey
okay let's see i wouldn't want a prude
who gives me rare inconsistent sex i
don't really think that's the case with
prudes to be honest but i don't know i
don't
it's like awkward i don't ask them about
their life with their husband like
that's
that's very uncomfortable um
i've seen virgin girls marry f boys
later that that might be the case for
you i i have never seen it
i have only seen girls that are virgins
marry religious guys
that's it
but
i know biologically like we are
we prefer men that have slept with more
more girls
because um
that's like mate selection but on the
other hand women are risk averse
so like the more girls you guys been
with the like higher risk he is
um
okay if men don't expect sex then women
will stop giving it up for
so so freely if you want a woman
the woman you're with
to have morals i
i disagree with you because
i have friends that waited till they
were married to have sex okay it did not
matter if that man
if that way
if that man like my friends that were
virgins even if a guy expected sex from
them like she wouldn't give it to them
like it's not on the men it's on us
like our decisions are our decisions um
um
never see a virgin would marry a [ __ ]
boy i mean i don't know
the numbers don't add up if you're only
saying 11 years it could be a two-year
sexual relationship in the rest focus on
other things
what do you mean add up okay
if a girl starts having sex at 16 okay
and she has
sex on and off for 11 years
all i'm saying is like
i don't know that's a long time stuff
probably happened in that 11 years i
don't
i don't know what it varies girl to girl
but you're never you're never really
gonna know um
that's not true
um if men stopped expecting sex from
women
women will stop giving it up and
stop putting out which stops you from
being nasty
okay but you're trying to
you're trying to change the biological
disposition of men men want to f
like they want to hook up with girls
that's that's how men are
like you're trying to you're trying to
change
how men are
and saying oh i made this decision
i made this decision so i'm going to
blame them
like ma'am
respectfully ma'am like that's on you
that's on you
oh my gosh
western society's view on sex
is not the end-all be-all a lot of
places still have virgins you all don't
know what's happening in india ethiopia
okay okay
that's
respectfully that that's a that's a dumb
argument
because i don't i don't live in those
places so i'm clearly not talking about
them
and most men
don't have the opportunity or want to
move to a different country
like the average guy makes what 45 55
000 a year
like
and if you can do that go do it sir go
do it but you're gonna you're gonna face
different problems
every decision you make has a
consequence okay
if you go get the virgin girl in a
different country that's gonna come with
having
one you have to fly to one place or the
other fly their family out for the rest
of your life like
you have to figure out how to make those
cultures mash it's not like
you get a virgin girl and there's no
consequences that
come with that decision of marrying
someone from a different country because
i grew up with people from different
countries like i literally grew up in a
nanny with nannies from people from all
over the world and i've seen some of
them
like i had some like marry my cousins
and like uncles like it was
and
let me it comes with a whole different
set of problems everything in life comes
with problems that's what i've realized
it's just like what problems do you pick
that's the question
um
if you tolerate a girlfriend who doesn't
like sex if she you wonder if she was
more sexual with other men in the past
that's the only reason to worry about
her body count um
i was referring to answering
about people [ __ ] talking virgins oh my
god no i would never i think that's the
ideal i always say like that's what i
wish i did
i didn't right
but god like if i could go back and
change one decision in my life that's
what it would be like i genuinely wish i
did
um
um oh my god this is what i hate about
the comment section you come in and you
say i said something that i clearly
didn't
that i clearly didn't okay
you think men are supposed to just screw
every single hole that he comes in
contact with that's insane this is
called dick control okay let me know in
the comments is that what i said
is that is that what i said
this is oh my gosh it's women we get so
emotional
no
no
what i said
is men are biologically predispositioned
to want to f
every girl like they want to spread
their seed that is that it and so i
we cannot put the burden on men
just like i'm not going to tell women
not to try to get the highest value guy
that they can
don't be delusional bad in your league
but
that's like telling women
we should be attracted to bums
we aren't sorry
that that's our bot that's their
biological
predisposition what i consider myself
purple pelt it's funny they always they
call me a red pill women woman i have
never called myself red pill i talk
about red pill topics
i understand the red pill very well
that's the same thing oh my gosh and
this is what this is the thing this is
why girls don't like my content because
it's not the same thing
everyone
has self-control and morals and values
that we put into place
but
going out into the world
and saying
oh they all expect me to have sex so
that's why i have sex that's like me
going outside and saying oh they all
expect me these homeless people that sit
outside my building all expect me
to give them money
so do i just give it to them
hell
no
hell no
just because men expect like like you
cannot expect the world to cater to you
you can't like that's like saying oh
there's bad man that'll like that expect
no it's uh it's you
you who you sleep with is your own fault
who you make a baby with is your own
fault
you think
like
why why is this such a a hard concept
for women to understand
and sometimes you're gonna get used like
it happens
take the l and move on
take it like
[Music]
also send a donation because i'm trying
to get four more mics i want eight mics
total
oh my god it just this makes me so mad
like women the first
chance we get will blame the men oh it's
the men
if they didn't expect sex from us then
we wouldn't do it what the are you crazy
are you crazy
bro
oh my god i don't even know what purple
pill is
sorry that's just oh my god that made me
so mad
oh the homeless people expect money from
me
if they didn't expect money from me i
wouldn't give it to them all the time
like what the
[Music]
what
oh my god
sorry i'm i'm chill
call mom and ask her thank you for the
20 super chat
i will call my mom and i will ask her
i will
she said stop giving me money or asking
me for money you need to pay for your
own [ __ ]
like mom what's the point of having rich
parents
if you guys don't spoil me please
oh call mom and ask her what what do i
ask my mom 20 super chat if you guys
this is absolute false that wanna met
all men that men want to have sex with
as many women as possible i do not i
only want to sleep with women i found
attractive and feel special
oh my god guys we're talking about in
general this is what i talk about like
it's like if i said okay
men are more masculine women are more
feminine i've even said i kind of like a
guy with a little bit of feminine energy
a little bit of a little bit of feminine
energy
okay
but we're talking about in generalities
in generalities men tend to want to f as
many women as possible because they're
biologically predispositioned to want to
spread their seeds women want to get the
highest value man because they want to
have the best jeans for their offspring
they want their kids to look good and be
productive and successful and it's our
job to make select and find the best guy
possible
and so telling women not to do that
that's like telling us to go against our
nature telling men to do that is like
telling them not to do that is to go
against their nature and it's okay you
should go against your nature sometimes
you absolutely should you should not
break a happy home just because you
think you could have done better sorry
you shouldn't
you should you should not break up a
family that you have built because you
think you could have done better okay
the second one
with men sleeping with as many people as
possible it's about
values morals character okay
men
still can go against their nature and be
monogamous to one woman they can't they
can't just like women can go against
their nature and not be hypergamous but
this is like
how we are in general okay there there's
obviously exceptions to every rule it's
not a hard concept to understand i'm old
af i've been through some things i just
wanna i just know that emotional woman
will do for men she favors stop being
emotional women wait i just know what
emotional woman will do for the man she
favors yes
oh my god like women
i have gone above and beyond for guys
that i like loved
and i am the archetype the archetype of
a girl that it's like
taken advantage of but but i've also
gotten a ton of things
like i've had
i've had men do very very nice things
for me
and in my opinion it's because i give a
lot and sometimes you're gonna get
bamboozled you're gonna get taken
advantage of that is life
that's life like [ __ ] happens take the l
ladies we need to be better about taking
l's and not bitching about it do you
know how many
men have taken outs with women where
they spend thousands of dollars on them
and they feel so used
sometimes
we get used
that's life oh my god we take l's
like everyone takes l's in dating
at some point i mean look it if you get
married at 21
are you getting married at 21
you're a virgin
you probably didn't to be honest you
probably did not take an l
you might have no idea what i'm talking
about but if you get married and you're
older like then a certain than a certain
age
you've probably taken an l
you're being overly emotional you're
acting like a woman with that being said
i expect you to understand my comments
who are you
guys guys
i'm passionate
maybe i am emotional but i'm right you
know i'm right
you're not right
i understand your comments perfectly
that's what we do as women we move the
goal post oh you don't know but actually
i really appreciate the donation like
very much thank you
sorry i know i'm like roasting you a
little bit right now i'm sorry
send me money that was actually really
nice fifty dollars and even
maybe it's my emotional nature
um
thank you thank you so much
like actually so much to be honest
like a hundred percent
i
am trying to get
this um
four mics all these donations are going
towards the four mics i'm gonna start a
podcast it's called the pre-game why
because the pre-game is better than the
party you have the best conversations at
the pre-game the pre-game at pearls
boom
boom and i live right next to campus i'm
gonna have college students from all
over the world i know girls from germany
i know girls from
all over the world okay they're gonna
come on the podcast some men too but
mostly hot girls donate for the hot
women
um
did the man that did very nice things
for you
um you did
what will the podcast feel about we're
going to talk about red pill topics
so we're going to talk about um
like relationship dynamics basically
yeah so it's going to be like
i like when you pound your fist sorry i
get passionate
i get passionate
maybe emotional i don't know it could it
could be emotion
i am and that's okay like guys women
being emotional is our superpower like
you can appeal to someone you can
convince someone of something
like like men
the manosphere
wants to [ __ ] on women that are
emotional
and it's true
we should and i don't want to say [ __ ]
on women
we should not be too emotional okay like
that that's a weakness
but our emotion is not a weakness it is
a strength because you can appeal to
people the most viral videos and most
influential moments in influential
movies have all appealed to emotion
okay okay
let me let me let me just bring you
let me let me just bring you a little
bit like
you have to watch a lot of red pill
before you really understand the ideas
and
some men will say things
and like they have these crazy
unrealistic expectations of women
um respectfully guys some of you do like
you make 45k a year and you want a woman
for that's a virgin
good luck
let me know when you find them
um you just kind of have to understand
that like there's a respectfully guys i
love you i love you audience but there's
a a good amount of us
a amount of you that are kind of like
insults a little bit a little bit i'm
i'm sorry i'm sorry i have to say it
love you appreciate the support
i so much
but i gotta be honest
um
men don't ask for a lot no you guys
don't in real life you don't in real
life you really don't
but sometimes when you watch the
manosphere
and i understand how women take this
you'll listen thank you so much for the
donation i appreciate it so much
so much so you don't even understand
but when you watch the manuscript first
you kind of have to understand like this
is all in generalities like for example
when i started watching the man of
sphere i would watch content that was
like don't don't go for a girl that's
like friendly because if she's friendly
she slept with a million people i'm like
damn
i can't be friendly
but what they're really talking about is
like the girl that has to be the center
of attention all the time that's what
they're talking about
that doesn't know how to let someone
talk that like the eyes always have to
be on her and
that it's like it's kind of hard to get
past because when you first start
watching manosphere content as a woman
like
like
you're just like damn like they're
nitpicking about every goddamn thing but
that that's content
most most guys in real life really don't
ask for that much to be honest most guys
are like
we'll go above and beyond for you to be
honest like men are very giving
um and thank you so much for the two
dollar super chat i don't get called hot
often that's
i'm gonna
stand up a little straighter i might
put on makeup next time um
i am making six figures and i'm over six
feet and in shape can i ask for more
yeah you can ask for what you want
you can ask for what you want it's like
what can you get what have you gotten
and what can you get and if you can't
get what you want why haven't you gotten
it like what's your deficit
that's the question um
red pill looks good in theory but a lot
of things have to be weighed um the girl
that hugs every guy door guy when you're
out it's a pass yeah fair enough um
women have their time to talk about
their issues with men for a year and
that's why and now that men have a voice
as women want to cry wolf i'm not crying
wolf guys what i'm saying is like
just like when women say men are trash
and i don't i don't like that comment i
don't i really do not appreciate women
that say that
what they're talking about is like
shitty things that have happened to them
and this is like the male equivalent of
that yeah so
i'm not look at it i think sometimes i'm
like y'all you guys are nitpicking about
everything
um
men should ask for a lot we're in the
ones
okay they were the ones who can make the
relationship happen so we get to be in
charge
okay i'm i'm sorry guys
but
i men should maybe but like can they
that's the question like do you have
that leverage in power
that's that's the question what what are
your results
like some men can but it's a very it's a
very small percentage i hate to i hate
to be the bearer of bad news i'm not
i'm just the messenger okay
like
um
or like you also start listening to the
manosphere and you're like
i don't know you just
you once you get to a certain point i'd
say it takes about six months of
hardcore watching the content for you to
like
realize who they're talking about like
guys they're talking about hoes that's
like who they're talking to they're
saying men avoid hoes i've had this
avoid the super friendly girl that's
like super flirty with every single guy
avoid this avoid that avoid that and you
have to understand like that's the
content avoid hoes basically
um
that like does that make sense like that
that's you have to understand but then
you know it's kind of like like
sometimes you're just like oh my god i
can't even exist without breaking one of
these like rules like one time i watched
like this thing that said okay if a girl
asks you what you're looking for
then then that means she was hoenn
before i'm like i can't
ask a guy what he's looking for without
them assuming that
and like they'll just go on it'll be
like every single sentence i'm like what
the
i can't say damn near anything
anyways um
um
[Music]
asking is a small part oh thank you so
much for the donation you guys you guys
are so nice like i appreciate this [ __ ]
so much
um
okay do you believe there's still a go a
going still ongoing gender war
um
i think it's i don't know if it's
because i'm older and i think like most
gender war stuff is like
kind of a young person thing
like the men are trash all this stuff is
like
i don't know more more for young people
in my opinion um
but it's definitely less than where it
was like when the kavanaugh stuff was
coming out like a couple years ago from
what i've seen
um but yeah there definitely is like
there's a population of women that hate
men and do not appreciate men at all
like they do not they don't
uh my husband is sixth ew
sir you're gonna get blocked if you keep
putting weird comments like that you
know who you are you know who you are
um there is a lot there's red pill
there's mgtow there's all kinds of green
black
blue pills yeah and that's the thing
when you first started watching red pelt
you're just like
i can't
i'm like
like i went on a show once donovan's i
love donovan donovan has been so helpful
and supportive of my youtube channel he
could say whatever the hell he wants
about women i do not care
i do not as long as he is helping me
i he could
don't care don't care i and he is so
nice to me but my first experience with
him was him telling me i'm tainted
because i had a black ex-boyfriend i'm
like
[ __ ] that is rude that is rude sir
but
i don't know i just don't care like who
and that's the thing is women like who
cares if he thinks i'm tainted like i
literally could not care less
like okay then think i'm tainted you
can't ever date a white guy again okay
well i don't care um
the red pale community basically says
avoid all women all women are able evil
to bid toxis men need to marry the
mother of their kids and you should
teach your children how to navigate this
yes
okay look we're coming back together um
no i absolutely agree with you
i do not they they want to [ __ ] on
single moms all day but
you you shouldn't be in a situation
where you're getting a girl pregnant
some of you guys are wilding you are
wilding you are nutting and random girls
that you don't know
like i'm sorry if you're a single
if you're a single dad and you did not
marry the mother of your kids if you get
divorced
that's not your fault a lot of the time
it's not your fault if she just left
because she thought she could do better
whatever
okay that you can't do [ __ ] about that
but if you did things out of order like
you have to take some responsibility for
it it's not all on the woman i'm sorry
it's not i know they want to say women
are
in charge of um
hold access to sex so they hold more
responsibility if they get pregnant i
agree because as a woman you are in
charge of your birth control you can
track your cycle there's so much more
that you can do
but like why do you guys put yourself in
that situation like you can always wear
a condom
you can always refrain from having sex
with ratchet chicks
so there is
i i i'm not a fan of like putting all
responsibility on either side if you put
yourself in a position where you had a
kid with a ratchet girl and you saw the
warning signs before and you still can
continue to nutting her like that sorry
that's your own fault just like it's
your own fault if you get pregnant by a
dusty ass dude that leaves like
you picked him
you pic especially if you're under 30
you have so much
oh
yeah um
okay where the red pill basically says
avoid a woman all women are evil you
have to understand okay when you become
a creator like you look through this
stuff
from a different lens they're doing it
for click bait it goes more extreme but
most of the guys like behind the scene
don't
have these like crazy extreme views to
be honest um
okay
what are your thoughts when it's a white
when it's white
it's right in the black eyesight do you
understand the meaning i don't know what
you're talking about damn this is sad
there's women who really hate men i
believe most women most men do not hate
women
um
women don't like condoms okay sir sir
this is what i'm gonna tell you if a
woman doesn't like a condom
wear it anyway who cares who cares what
she likes
this is about you
this is about you sir that's like okay
that's like
me saying
oh well men um
he he didn't like to
he he didn't like to wear a condom
and
um
yeah so i'm gonna just not and now i'm
surprised when i get pregnant like
no sir
don't nut and ratchet females
like you can always wear a condom that
is like the most
probably i would guess the most
effective form of birth control like
um
okay let's see
red pill doesn't say what i don't
remember what you're talking about um
we do
care what kind of money you have there's
a medium
large that gets out of my who okay oh
yeah women marriage is not a fairy tale
it's a beautiful thing that comes with
responsibility yeah guys
marriage is not a fairy tale like it
sounds really hard
my parents have been married
for like 25 plus years there were years
where they did not like each other like
it was not all sunshine and rainbows and
that was like the typical like high
value man whatever
man of value i don't
i don't know
like
like [ __ ]
real femme sapien a condom is one dollar
child support is 18 years
yeah
like don't get me wrong but you guys
know that women are hypergamous what did
drake do
what did drake do
he got a porn star pregnant he said
never again
never again
so what am i gonna do hot sauce
i'm not saying it's wrong like you guys
he shouldn't have to go to that length
but
[Music]
this is the world we're in you can't
like people are shitty like
i can't make i can't make the world
better but i can't you can protect
yourself
oh my god
um steph is cold says you don't have a
girlfriend because they finesse
and then he had a long-term girlfriend
that's the red pill talking points but
not living in
reality except for alpha male strategies
um
you have to watch enough red pill
content yeah well
duh like
because at the end of the day like women
aren't perfect and neither are men so
you have to understand every guy that's
teaching red pill something brought him
here
the guys that are happily married and
the girls that are happily married like
they're not in this space
why like you had to have some deficit in
relationships
to find this stuff
normally okay there's exceptions so
don't be like oh this person's an
exception okay they're exceptions
they're not the rule um
men if you are a loose man do not get
into a committed relationship and
definitely don't get married be
dedicated or be a man who you can't be
both
true
true
okay speaking facts
like well actually actually you can have
both if you're rich enough let's be
honest jay-z
there are many men that are rich enough
to do it and girls will look the other
way i'm sorry it's not a fun reality we
live in right that's not that's not fun
that's not that's not exciting like am i
excited about that information
no
of course not
of course the f not oh my god
but yeah some guys can get away with it
and the girl's like you know what
i'm gonna go cry in my ferrari
on my yacht whatever
um
bread i just have to figure out why
women will call masculinity toxic
but they're not attractive
to effeminate men they'd still prefer a
masculine man i kind of like a little
feminine
i'm sorry i'm sorry i like i like the
funny guys i don't
i
i like the funny guys are the guys that
don't talk
and just let me ramble forever and
barely listen
um
when am i getting married hopefully
sooner rather than later but
i'm still like guys i'm not
over my ex-boyfriend so i need to like
get over that before i bring anyone into
this madness
um
how many times have you heard women say
that we're perfect oh my god all the
time like women are queens women are
they might not say the word perfect but
the family is dead look at mass media
and promoting single
motherhood like rihanna and asap
um
how do i put it
you have to understand ryan is a
billionaire if i was a billionaire i
i'm sorry i would not get married i
wouldn't i this is [ __ ] i kind of have
to think about sort of like it i don't
it's going to be much later in my life
i'm not a trust fund kid i'm not going
to like get this trust fund anytime soon
but i know that at some point i'm going
to inherit a good amount of money and
when i do
i don't want to be in a position where
like some dude can take it
no my dad worked hard for that for me
and my family
that hopefully this guy is a part of his
like i don't know i just
i kind of understand men's perspective
on that because i'm like well i don't
like i'll i'll i'll get a prenup for me
like
not you
funny is feminine um they always say
that the funny guy like
it's not good like i've heard that a lot
um
some women don't qualify for high value
men from genetics alone it's not in the
cards yeah that's true
that is true but the problem is women
are so bad today that i feel like women
can like
kind of bat higher than they their
league technically
also you can get a high value man if
you're just younger and like go older
like the bigger the age gap
because
much contrary to you guys's belief most
girls i know that are 25 like don't want
to date 45 to 50 year olds
no no hate on you
no hate on you you know you and your man
look happy you're so in love with him
um
but that's just not that's not the norm
and i think you could probably attest
that that's really not the norm
um
uh let's see let's see let's see
you know what i can't stand about
females today if you try to talk to them
whether you're attractive or not it's
makes it count as creepy or sweet that's
so superficial
yeah look at it
that's what i say
pretty people get privileges it's not a
fun reality it's just life
okay
if you went on a date with a victoria's
secret model you'd probably take her on
a nicer date than me
look at it
that's life
um
like i don't
you know what i can't stand about female
okay wait uh you said on one of your
calls do you think women determine when
a man is alpha that isn't true men
determine did i say that
you're probably right i probably didn't
mean that one
you're right you're i would agree with
you the man i would say probably
i haven't thought this this thought
through that much so you know give me
give me a little grace here but
yeah i would say like the men
respect
men
that
like they have to do because women like
pre-selection so there's probably
something to that you're probably right
yeah um
a real alpha men should be married and
have at least five kids to carry on
their legacy that's what my dad did my
dad is the best my dad is cooler than
any of these red pill content creators i
love my dad so much you don't even
understand my mom too
they're cooler than everyone
um what is it about your ex-boyfriend
that made him attractive um
um he was funny he was hilarious he was
so funny and
he didn't i hate guys that are so like
i'll end it with a guy if they're too
pushy for sex
i don't i don't like that like i
there's nothing that gives me like the
ick faster than a guy that just won't
leave me alone when i say no
like because before i met him i hadn't
slept with anyone in two years so
i
um
i don't know i i told him that and like
he was so patient with it
and like
then like later it was me like always
initiating it because he was like
patient but i do not like
yeah that there's nothing that will give
me the ick faster than a guy that like
won't leave it alone and like starts
like come on like begging like oh my god
it's so unattractive um
the silent guys who let you ram
ramble are usually more masculine it's
stoicism
probably um smart women will get a man
now according to cnn 45 of women 25 to
44 will be childless
54 of women over 40
a wave of desperate women is coming
yeah maybe i'm i'm kind of in a
different position though
um
but i don't know i think there'll be a
reset
like i think there'll be a reset yes
it's hotter when they don't beg yes or
if they're just like so patient with you
like
oh my god guys and they'll be like and
then rollo will be like oh it's not
genuine desire if she doesn't sleep with
you immediately i'm like look at i have
had the most genuine desire for the most
patient man where like at first i was
like no no like hold off and then like
the tables like turn or you're the one
initiating i don't know look at it you
guys you guys can say it's not genuine
desire i don't care i disagree um
all my girlfriends that have rich
husband married 12 to 30 years older i
saw my man's potential and waited
because i didn't want an old man yeah
that's true would i approach a guy that
i'm interested in yeah
i mean i'm i'm getting pretty nervous in
person so
i would say i like
i mean i have again i'm not really
looking for anything right now um
but
yes it's hotter when they don't but yeah
and then like
yeah then anyways
um
most men talk too much and kill their
chances with a woman but in reverse when
you get into a relationship you're not
trying to have her sit around rambling
yeah
um
if you say no
then you are not into him see that's
what they say but i'm telling you like
i've been
i've had two guys that i was like
obsessed with like
one in college and one
like two boyfriends basically that that
like i put a lot in both of those
relationships and
both of them were so patient with me
because i just
yeah both of them were very patient
and very much like
yeah so
i don't know i think men are so afraid
of wasting time that they almost like
get desperate they're like so afraid
what if what if she
doesn't um
you saw my en ganu i don't i don't know
what that is um
i agree with you on that act like sex
isn't that important and she will be all
over you yeah
that's that's game right there also guys
feel free to do a donation remember this
this is going to be called the pregame
the the podcast that i'm gonna do why
because pregame conversations are always
the best conversations it's better than
the party everyone's a little buzzed
it's a smaller group so you can like
have more one-on-one talks
and you talk about like damn near
everything like your life story
your
everything you talk about
so
that being said
my goal is i think the perfect pregame
is like 8 to 12-ish people
right now i have a sound board and the
mics for four
my goal is to get the soundboard and the
mics for eight
right now
i raised a thousand dollars in the first
week that was amazing you guys never
cease to amaze me
um i
i want to say i've made like 75 bucks
from this live ish
out of the 900 great great start
i would really appreciate
especially if you've watched a couple of
my videos i work very hard anyone that's
followed me for a while knows i post all
the time
and i i work very incredibly hard do i
work smart probably not you know that's
a conversation for a different day
so
if you enjoy my videos please consider
sending a donation even if it's just
five dollars
like even it's just two dollars like
every dollar counts
and i want to put on like a great show
that is my goal i think this is going to
be a phenomenal show i have access
to my college i live right next to my
college i can have college girls on all
the time
and college men
but like
you guys are mostly men i know you're
here for the ladies all right they're
attractive they're athletes they're from
all over the world like germany japan
india like i i can get girls from all
over the world
and i think if i could get eight it
would be cool and then on top of that
i would like to get um
some background like decorations and
stuff okay
um get the rode caster pro i did i have
that that only hosts four mics though
that only hosts four so my goal is if i
raise another nine hundred dollars i can
get
it might be like a thousand another
thousand-ish bucks i can get another
four mics and another road caster pro so
i can host eight microphones and have
eight people on right now
i have five mics and i i can hook four
of them up to the road caster and maybe
one up to my pc i have to see the
equipment gets here today
so
yeah i really
i'm not i'm not a beggar but i will beg
okay um if a woman woman love feeling
chosen by a man with many options why do
so many women wait until they're 30 plus
and running out of options before
picking a man um i would say it's the
paradox of choice like if you have too
many options you're less happy with your
choice
that's why like the most happy marriages
i see are just like regular people that
got married it's a paradox of choice
honestly
um
do you guys like my shorts by the way
do i really want to have six to eight
girls on at the same time no i want to
have like
okay i think the perfect amount would be
six people
that's that's what i think i think
like four
girls ish and like two guys i think
would be perfect
ten dollars thank you so much
thank you oh my gosh i appreciate it so
much i think we're at like 85ish dollars
i can't see all the super chats at once
but i really really appreciate it you
guys know i work very hard i'm a very
hard worker and i'm going to work so
hard to make this show like really good
for you guys i swear to god i'm going to
work so hard
partially because i i need to pay rent
and it's coming up
i'm a little nervous but i swear to god
this is going to be a great show
i i know it i'm a hard worker i'm good
at asking questions i'm a good host and
there's no girl in the red pill that has
her own live show there's no one no one
doing this
um
and there's no one um
yeah
you might want to try to get used but
used to before you try six or eight you
can have too many oh absolutely i'm
gonna start with four
i'm gonna start with four for sure
that's gonna be the first
four or five
but
i don't know you gotta guys i'm a
long-term thinker
i like to see everything long-term
okay
and i just know that long-term
like six to eight is gonna be good the
majority girls one or two guys on the
podcast
to kind of like represent men you know
and there's no red pill content creator
doing this there's not i mean there's
guys that are male-led
but i'm not going to bring on super
ratchet girls i really want to represent
normal girls
normal ones
i think she might start off with just
two people on the panel then work her
way up look at
i just look at i want six to eight
that's my vision you guys cannot agree
with my vision
my vision is like six to eight
that that's what i think is a good
pregame conversation like five
five to eight five to eight
and
the closer i can get to that the better
it's just my just my opinion
um
the first show will probably be like
four i'll probably bring my friend gaby
on
how much cleavage will be on the show
how ratchet do you want the girls
um i my goal is to bring on more like
normal girls but
look at if you if you send me a 100
donation right now
i will get a girl with cleavage i will
get you some
some girl with some tits i will i'll do
it 100 donation
i'll let you
i will
get a girl to put her boobs out um
um better bachelor is good with the
sound board too i want to be a guest are
you in london
why would i want you to be a guest or do
you have a channel
i would have to
i actually want to do um
uh
a giveaway or something where i like fly
one of my subscribers out to like be on
the [ __ ] that's later this is just an
idea i have for later but like where you
could like win i don't know like somehow
i would raise money like i don't know
um
asking for sex is the only way to ask
see if a girl is really interested
um girls guys who friend zone themselves
take the risk of getting ghosted
suddenly no reason um
i'm telling you the guys i've had the
most like burning like genuine desire
for
they didn't push it
i i disagree i 100 disagree
um
like a thousand i i think you're wrong
i'm sorry
um
i would
think europe would be worse in terms of
modern dating um i look it send me a
donation find out
find out
the the problem is a lot of my friends
are athletes and they're american
um a lot of them are also from like all
over the world there's like two teams
um
i'm not trying to have sex with somebody
that felt pressured that's how you catch
a case that's true today is
not nowadays like
so shisha said had a show where he said
what did he say he said something along
the lines of like
like no doesn't mean no and i know what
he meant like a girl would be like ah no
but i don't i just think it's kind of
creepy to keep pushing it
i don't know there's a way you guys
there's nothing that gives me the ick
faster than when i say no and a guy just
doesn't leave it alone like there's
nothing that like makes me
feel so gross
and just be like get get off me
you
have a f um
you have a firm
stance unbreak some red pill stuff
it can't
be a purely informational show of course
not no it's entertainment
we're gonna have debates like i'm gonna
be debating these girls
i'm going to be like talking about
different
concepts and like different
like for example um i want to talk about
like when is the ideal time do you guys
want to get married and have kids sooner
or later why
um
i think okay but this is this is what i
think it is about sex we like a guy that
we know
can
get sex
but doesn't just like demand it from us
because we want to feel like we earned
it almost
i think that's like
oh my gosh i
no doesn't mean no but it doesn't mean
be pushy it just means you understand
that woman
don't always say what they mean yeah
that's true and then hit them with the
cold hard facts yes that's what i want
to do
i want to be like bam this stop bam this
stat i'll be like the stats [ __ ]
for real sen send
send the donation send it send it sends
it send it
but how black
[Music]
um
oh my gosh i have a guitar lesson in
like five minutes i do not feel like
doing it
but i have to
oh my gosh i have to because i'm trying
to i'm trying to do shows i actually do
sing
i'm not
i'm better at youtube than i am at
singing like money wise obviously
but
okay guys
thank you so much for watching i think
this is a really fun show
um
if for the support if pearl reads one or
more of your comments you'll need to
donate yes
thank you
thank you
yes
i'm so tired of all of you guys watching
my content all the time and never
donating help a girl out
this is gonna give me the money to make
better content for you guys for you
like i'm gonna i'm i promise you i swear
to god this is going to be the most
entertaining show
the podcasts where the
where the hosts railroad the guests with
the facts are boring they don't have
real conversations but guys you know me
you know my personality
i'm not i'm not a [ __ ]
i'm very agreeable watch watch my my
live my interviews with normal people
playlist
i talk to people that i disagree with
all the time
all the time
it's
you know
you know you know me you you watch my
[ __ ]
i
can you make a we have beef shirt yes i
want to
soon soon i will that's on my right now
i'm trying to figure out this
um
i meant sexually making the first move
and not being scared of rejection yes
yes not begging or pressuring for sex
yes
yes
that's true
um
am i on the east coast no i'm in london
i live in london and someone asked me
why i moved to london
and it's because i wanted to play
volleyball i'm trying to go pro next
year maybe we'll see um
thank you i did read a bunch of your
comments
i did i'm a comment reader
i read the comments
thank you
thank you fifty dollars
oh my god you guys are changing my life
you don't even understand
oh my god just because
it's obviously you work hard the
algorithm pushed your videos my way and
you keep coming great work i can't wait
to see how your podcast goes can you
please bring out baby mama culture as a
topic yes
yes let's
let's
also i want to i want to do a show
called it's your own fault if you get
knocked up by a deadbeat dad
if he married you and then becomes a
dead beat down dad sure
sure that's not your fault you did it it
seemed like things were going to go a
different way
but if you made a baby with the man that
you weren't married to what did you
think was gonna happen ma'am
anyways oh my gosh thank you this i had
to have made like 125-ish bucks on the
show
ish ish i don't i can't see them all
together
but thank you thank you so much i
i appreciate it i appreciate it so much
like
like i could cry sometimes from these
super chats
like
y'all don't even understand i
this like this past year this past six
months my videos have kind of died
and i have been working so hard and
making like no money and i'm just
i know one of these days something is
gonna hit i have a great feeling about
this podcast i know it's gonna be good i
know it i work so hard and i know this
is a good idea i've put a lot of time
and money and effort into bad ideas i
have i work hard i don't work smart this
is why i need a man in my life
to help me work smarter
five dollars thank you so much
thank you
for five dollars for reading my comment
now tell us more about yourself and
don't worry we won't tell anyone else
what do you want to know my life is an
open book
i have nine siblings i grew up in a half
a percent family my dad's the typical
high value man except i don't know if he
has the high value man like network like
he kind of just sticks to himself but
he's not a complete loner i don't know
he's arguably a high value man and
[Music]
i love red pill like it's so fun
um grilling girls with red pill content
this would be the low hanging fruit
would make pearl's channel popular no
i'm gonna do [ __ ] different i am
respectful of my guests i am respectful
i don't
watch watch my interview pot i i'm still
organizing it i made a lot of videos
again i work smart hard not smart i'm
trying to organize them all in the
playlist but the interviews playlist
that i have you should go watch because
i have girls that i adamantly disagree
with all the time
all the time
and
i'm telling you i don't have a problem
where
like
women get mad or like whatever they
might not like what i have to say but
i'm respectful
i'm not gonna yell at you i'm not gonna
call you a hoe i'm not gonna do any of
that [ __ ] that's not me that's not my
personality
um
oh my gosh uh let's see
my guitar last teacher i think is
running a couple minutes late because i
do not have the email from her
like she'll usually email me a link
what do i love most about red pill i
love psychology
and i'm nosy like i like to know what
you guys talk about
okay
i'm a nosy [ __ ]
um
you don't have to be mean about it no
i'm not i'm not mean i'm like
i'm not a mean girl i'm really not
i'm a
i'm a i'm a i'm a nice [ __ ] but i'm i'm
an opinionated
i'm nice but i'm very opinionated
so that's what people don't that's
that's where i'm like the silent
assassin what do they call that's what
they call ally sorry i stole that but
because i'm like pretty nice and like
friendly and [ __ ] so people like me
but then boom opinions strong opinions
at that
i won't sit down and shut up i won't do
it i won't
um
okay guys wait 9 30 10 30 11 30 1 30 2
30.
oh gosh okay guys i need to go
i need to go
i'm already late to this guitar lesson
okay i love you i love you all
thank you so
freaking much for the donations i could